I don't know.
Is it confusing?
Is it simple?
I don't know what to think
about this case.
It's simple --
the dog didn't --
The dog didn't
eat the hair.
How do you know that?
It was, uh -- For the dog,
that hair was, uh, a toy.
The hair wasn't food.
Little Mama's mama
is saying that, um...
[ Water bubbling ]
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughing continues ]
Thanks for giving me time to
think of what I was gonna say.
-Yes.
-Uh...
She's saying -- She's saying
that the package never arrived.
Just accusing the dog
of eating it
is like that's why
it didn't get there.
Oh, I thought
the defendant was saying...
But package theft is
a huge problem in this country.
Who is -- Right.
[ Coughs ]
Wait. So, I thought
the dog owner --
Like, you ever wake up and all
of your genitals are gone?
[ Both laugh ]
I really couldn't
tell the difference
between the regular one
and this one.
I thought the dog owner
was saying,
"Oh, my dog didn't
eat the hair."
And so I'm on
Team Dog Didn't Eat the Hair.
Right.
And so
I'm on Team Dog Owner.
Yeah, okay.
Do we give
the full $2,500...
[ Bag pops ]
Oh, no.
I didn't mean to --
No, don't pop
the hair bag.
I'm sorry.
I -- [ Laughs ]
[ Water bubbling ]
So, the --
So, who won?
So -- Well, no.
Like, Little Mama won,
but that means...
the defendant won?
I don't approve
of Little Mama's owner
letting her -- letting us
take Little Mama.
Yeah, the verdict is,
Little Mama's a sweetie...
[ Coughing ]
She's very well-behaved
in a kidnapped environment.
[ Laughs ]
'Cause
for all she knows --